[Music]
on today's show we talk about
relationships and how to talk to kids
about hard things
one of these calls in particular a woman
calls and asks
can i still be dating a guy who lives
with his ex-girlfriend oh gosh stay
tuned
[Music]
hey what's up everybody this is john
with the dr john dolone's show
man
happy new year happy february
happy whatever
i don't know happy marriage life work
good stuff
is that right ben
that's right
that's so affirming man thanks dude um
hey i hope you're doing well
over the last few weeks um in ways i
didn't expect these so everybody know we
sold out of these things one two three
times and now this is the fourth time
the conversation cards we are have them
back in stock
if one of your new year's resolutions
was to connect more with your kids to
have different kinds of dates with your
spouse or somebody you're dating
or to like be more intentional about
being in touch with your grandparents
whatever dude these cards i'm all over
the planet earth people are sending me
pictures of how these things interacted
with him kelly you were telling me about
something that you got the other day
what was this
yeah we got a really cool email from a
listener who said that she bought the
ones i guess for the couples
and um they
did them one night and everything was
great and she found out something she
didn't know which was what was his
favorite cereal
as a child she's like oh what was your
favorite childhood cereal and why yeah
and so the next time she went to the
store she bought some of that cereal and
then she came home and she sent us a
picture and told us how excited he was
that they just sat at the table and ate
cinnamon toast crunch together and how
it was awesome early morning
part out luckily
yeah maybe not maybe not but um it all
starts with cinnamon toast crunch or
whatever whatever it is what was your
cereal going up fruity pebbles
what was yours been
i think like tricks
tricks yeah
god i was so little
was like crackling o'brien or something
or yeah that's disgusting actually maybe
that explains a lot of my digestive
issues this many years later but
dude i love me some cinnamon toast
crunch all right
i love old cereals that's awesome well
hey you can go to johnoling.com and get
these cards they're not expensive man
and really some of them are cheesy some
of them are deep some are lame some of
them are funny
but just good ways you know my wife was
talking about how it gives everybody an
opportunity to take turns and sometimes
when you get people together whether
it's one domineering
partner in a dating relationship or
you're out with a few people at dinner
and there's just that one idiot that's
usually me that just won't shut up keeps
talking talking talking and these are a
good way to teach everybody to take
turns around a table which is awesome
anyway check them out let's go to
elizabeth and michael in twin cities
twin cities
minnesota what's up guys
hello
hello what's happening
oh well it's finally above zero i was
gonna say
how cold is it there one
is it so cool
like four today
four degrees that's unconscionable and
it's been negative for a while
as a kid who grew up in texas that just
seems like
i know they're you know
the the whole story about hell is it's
hot that i can't imagine living in a
place where it was negative that seems
like hell to me is it is it not
um
you get used to it just kind of get used
to it it's a dry cold or i don't know
whatever they say right
cali
all right so uh what's up with you two
how can i help
well um
we've just uh recently started dating
and uh
within a space where uh
i have kids from a time managed
two young kids five and nine
and uh
and uh and she does not
so
uh becoming
into this from different places
right for me the uh
the kids and
and what's best for them is super
important
and i kind of feel like when we talk
about this we're both a little clueless
on how to proceed
um
i
feel like my kids have had enough to
remind their lives from uh
uh
from dissertation with my mom
and
i want to know what's best for them
but i don't really know how to navigate
that yeah
and and
kind of let you speak for yourself and i
know that you're coming from your own
space yeah i'd love to hear your side of
this elizabeth
um so we've been dating for a while
like how long is a while
um about five months now okay
um
and like him i'm clueless
really want to do things the right way
and set kind of you know
have a relationship that can be a model
for a healthy adult relationship
but
don't know what that looks like or where
to start when i don't have kids so you
know dogs and cats are much easier
dude somebody bought me a mug
brad bought me a mug and just says cat
dad on it it's incredible not a thing
elizabeth not a thing um so first i want
to applaud both of you for
wanting to do this thing right on behalf
of these two little ones um most times
i'm talking to folks there's a
selfishness there that they just need to
figure out themselves because i got to
be me and blah blah blah and you two
sound like you are
really thoughtful human beings and so i
want to applaud you for that that's
awesome
um okay so we can get into this a little
bit but i'm gonna ask some awkward
questions that y'all may not be ready to
answer
in front of a couple million people is
that cool
and so y'all y'all um
the two of you i'll frame these
questions as things you can answer now
or later and you can just feel free to
say uh later and y'all can talk about
this on your own is that cool
interesting
um all right so michael you mentioned
that their kids were traumatized by
previous mom does previous mom believe
this
is she would she be telling me if she
called my show would she be telling me
that their dad's nuts and whatever or is
there some clear
you know challenges with mom
um there's some clear challenges that
want she has um diagnosed mental health
she's to a certain extent okay so do the
kids have contact with her
they do i mean i i don't want her to
sound like an absolutely crazy person
she's not but she does have some mental
health um challenges sure but she
she also wants the best for the kids but
uh
but let's just say it ended up with a
lot of drama that was infected on the
kids sure there you go and then how long
have you been separate from her
separated from her um
two and a half almost three years now
okay okay so three years has she started
dating again
no
do you two
have you all talked about this have you
all had this conversation here's how
we're going to approach this if one of
us starts dating
or here's how we're going to decide who
else is around our kids have you had
that conversation or is that a no-go
with the
the kid's mom no yeah
and that's that's also a non-starter
like there is no communication between
us okay so that conversation would never
happen okay all right
um and elizabeth tell me what you think
about this michael guy how'd you meet
him
online
uh he's pretty great yeah
takes care of kind of everyone in his
life and
funny smart responsible
cute i was gonna say is he handsome all
right good
very what what uh
very gross gross
um what
what is it about him
and these two little ones that makes you
think i want to get deeper into their
world
he's incredible and from everything i've
seen about the two girls they're pretty
incredible too
i really want a family and i could see a
really
amazing uh kind of joyful building life
future there
okay
so here's kind of the global rules um if
you will not there's not really rules i
guess but the global recommended
practices are
whenever you get divorced but if you get
separated um
and this is different than if somebody
passes away
wait at least a year right so you've
done that it creates some space between
this and that
the second thing that i think is
important for everybody to understand is
sometimes these kids will feel like
they are
having to choose sides and so there may
be moments where elizabeth if they're
nice to you
they will feel like they're betraying
their mom
even if their mom is totally supportive
and wonderful i was like no daddy's this
is she's a great you know this daddy's
new girlfriend elizabeth is awesome but
that we put these kids in this situation
so you're gonna have to go into this
knowing
that
the things that a five-year-old and a
nine-year-old say to me over the next
one year two years ten years
are not gonna be personal it's gonna be
them working out which side am i on
which team am i on who does that make
sense
yeah
um
and then the the big challenge i have to
you two is this
um
michael tell me about elizabeth what
makes what makes elizabeth worth getting
back into this game that that hurt you
and your kids last time
i guess created your kids there's that
but
well i mean
i don't even know where to start i mean
she's just amazing
she uh
she's
she represents a lot of things that i
never directly like i never had in my
life a partner who is very level-headed
very focused
very supportive
um
the time we spent together she
she is completely in sync with
everything that we do she she works with
me
on pretty much anything that we
want to do
i don't know i feel supported i feel
like i'm with an actual partner not
someone that i have to carry along
um
she looks amazing
[Laughter]
come on michael
no but uh seriously i mean i see like
most of my life i carry people along
and
when i'm with someone that doesn't need
to be carried and is willing to uh
shoulder up with me but it's a pretty
different feeling i've
never quite felt that way before
so
that's awesome that's awesome so the one
the one hang up i have with all this is
this is the five month number
and
the question you all have to ask each
other is this
we've known each other for five months
um
he's so cute
she looks amazing
she's a great partner um he is caring
and all these things
um
is there legs beyond five months
and
i changed my mind i won't ask all that
publicly y'all can answer that on your
own
make sure you uh and this is i'm talking
to you michael make sure you are
see some legs on this thing
before you introduce her to your
daughters
and i would start with this is daddy's
new friend
and go to this is daddy's special friend
and that will take a period of weeks in
a period of months
and elizabeth you're gonna feel like you
are being hedged at some point
or it's gonna feel like it's what could
feel like it's gonna feel like you're
dating a guy
and he won't invite he won't introduce
you to his friends like at the bar he's
like hey i want you just to sit over
here and go talk to my buddies and
you're gonna be thinking i wanna go meet
your friends why are you hiding me it's
gonna feel like that a little bit and
you're gonna have to be really
level-headed and really um you're gonna
have to get your needs met somewhere
else
does that make sense
yep and to be clear when we're talking
about this it's pretty future looking
it's not like in the next month yeah i
got you i got you um
but you are gonna have to you're gonna
want to do things because this is
natural i would if i was you i would
want to do things that would assure that
these girls love me i want to help them
with their hair i want to help them with
school i want to talk to them about deep
things i want to go shopping with them
and there's going to be some
really careful baby steps into this
where they invite you into these
conversations so you're going to be
creating a world where they feel safe
enough to come to you
but when you force them into hey i want
to talk about this or tell me who you
have a crush on
then bam now you're forcing them am i
choosing her or my mom
right does that make sense and that's
gonna be hard hard hard and so
frustrating
so frustrating and then one day they'll
come to you and be like
can you not gonna believe this this boy
wants to kiss me or i found somebody at
school i'm in love with whatever you're
gonna talk about it's gonna be deep and
you're gonna go to bed and you're gonna
tell michael you'll be like oh my gosh
they trust me it's gonna be so great and
the next morning they're not gonna talk
to you because they're gonna feel
ashamed that they
betrayed their mom right it's gonna be
this back and forth thing that happens
and michael they're gonna want you to be
happy because you sound like an amazing
father they're gonna want you to be
happy and lovely and oh my like i can't
believe dad is doing this and who knows
what mom's gonna say right
so it's just expecting that you're gonna
have a picture that this is all gonna
work out perfect and it might in a long
game it's just gonna be hard
and maybe none of this happens maybe
your daughters are amazing you've they
are just understanding and they're like
dad you deserve to be happy and mom's a
little whoa
and
like we are really excited and i've seen
that before too so it's being honest
honest honest and making sure hey we're
in this for the long haul and then a
slow slow introduction not hey this is
dad's new girlfriend she's moving in
uh girls y'all gonna be bunking up
because like that would be traumatic
yeah right and you all know that you all
know that um michael so is elizabeth it
i'm sorry could you say it again is
elizabeth it
i'm making it weird now i'm so excited
even kelly looked up and she's like
do what
liz is it oh gross liz is
hey y'all get married here in the studio
that'd be so great
let's figure that out um but yeah hey i
i'm fully in support of y'all having
this conversation for those listening
the broader conversation you got to
waste some time you can't get a divorce
and then start dating somebody a month
later and introduce them to your kids as
hey this is daddy's boyfriend or this is
daddy's girlfriend or this is whatever
you can't do that you got to give these
kids some space because it it it
it uproots everything in their life
the second thing is by the way not a new
mommy either elizabeth not a new mommy
they've got a mom right and
unless there's somebody passes i mean
they don't have a mommy
understand that kids may view friendship
or connection or
like i'm gonna start calling you mom
they they're gonna have this betrayal
feeling that's gonna be deep deep deep
and oh my gosh
wait until there's a level of commitment
till i think this is serious
because then the
girls will feel the sense of trust and
okay we're gonna trust again and then if
y'all break up
man now they're back into well we lost
somebody else that we could lean into
and trust and now it's just us and dad
and dad sounds great but man that's hard
on kids hard on kids hard on kids
and i recognize moms and dads that's not
fair that these are none of this is fair
these are your kids
and they always always always come first
their trauma comes first let me put it
that way i think we over put our kids
first and a lot of other things but when
it comes to relationships their safety
and their trauma especially that they
experience in divorce comes first before
your need to do let's go out to the club
stop
take care of your kids we'll be right
back on the dr john elon show
y'all know there are lots of things that
make me nuts but one thing makes me more
nuts than anything else
buying a home and my friends who
refinance their homes they tell me it
makes them nuts too
i love living in a new home but i gotta
be honest
i'm no good at buying one and that's why
i'm so thankful for people like my
friends at churchill mortgage churchill
is a ramsey trusted provider who we've
been sending people to for over 20 years
to help with home mortgages why
because they're committed to doing
what's right for you and that means
walking you through paperwork that's way
over your head that means making sure
you get the right mortgage that you can
pay off as soon as possible and they'll
try to upsell you a bunch of nonsense
that's going to hurt you down the road
and most importantly when you're making
this big life change you can actually
breathe cause you got an expert in a
team who have your back listen if you're
about to buy a home and make a big
change save yourself the headache and
call churchill mortgage today at triple
eight loan 200. trust me that's triple
eight loan 200.
this is a paid advertisement in mls id
1591 nmls consumeraccess.org equal
housing lender 1749 mallory lane suite
100 brentwood tennessee 37027 programs
are for select loan types only and are
not available in all states or locations
all right we are back let's go to tim
also in minnesota what's up tim how we
doing man
hey dr john how are you good what's
going on man
uh not too much man
um
so i just uh was looking for some
clarity here i know you always say
don't lie to your kids i'm just
wondering where hold on
just just starting it with this makes
this my favorite call of the of the year
so far so i know you say don't lie to my
kids but
this is going to be good so what is it
um
so me and my wife are just wondering
where we draw that line at um as
brother just get it what'd you do
we were both
in a relationship uh
when we met and my oldest daughter was
conceived hey oh there it is we all
married
uh no no okay
so y'all were just dating other people
and then
yeah some say love
and then all she wrote and then your
daughter was like hey oh and so are you
all married now
yes we are okay how are things
uh they're good they're good
have you all cheated on each other since
i'm sorry have you all cheated on each
other since then uh there has been some
infidelity god almighty quit y'all are a
bunch of cheaters why
uh that's a good question oh it wasn't
you
uh it's been both of us oh my god quit
cheating all right what's your question
that's a whole other call
oh well we just
what do we
what do we tell our daughter as far as
you know how we met and
what happened there i mean how much is
too much for her
how old is she
uh right now she's five so we got some
time no i think you tell her everything
today i think you tell her that mom and
dad are a bunch of cheaters and no don't
tell her that good gosh
all right um
okay big picture stop cheating both of
you quit stop yeah right
quit yep quit
what have you done to say to make sure
this never happens again
uh
like what have you done
what have i done yes
in your life so that you never cheat
again
because this is your second relationship
that you've done this in a row and it's
not your first either
yeah um
not cheated anymore no no no no it
doesn't start there where what have you
done have you got all rid of all the
social media apps
you're never going to go on lunches with
a with a female co-worker ever again
like what have you what what roadblocks
have you put in front of yourself to
keep this from happening again
um
i mean we haven't deleted all social
media but we have limited what what we
use
um i don't particularly have any female
co-workers
okay
all right so here's the thing number one
you all got to get in the room and
figure this out because you'll be having
this conversation in divorce court with
your daughter and it's going to be a
mess don't do that to her okay
yep the second thing is this
um
the honesty rule even though you asked
that question so great it's so good man
so i know you say never lie um
yes you still don't lie
but don't over share to make yourself
feel better
okay and a lot of parents have this
sense of guilt um hey we had this kid
out of you know out of wedlock or we
were both married to somebody else then
we hooked up and got pregnant now this
kid
and it feels like i've gotta atone for
all my sins with this kid i'm gonna dump
all my crap onto this child just so i
can there's no don't do that to a kid
that's too much right that's this toxic
over-sharing world we live in now
so i think you're honest for a long long
time
and you tell them what they what she
wants to know when she asks questions so
for instance what's your origin story
how'd you meet she doesn't have to know
you are dating other people
she just
knows how you met how'd y'all meet
uh through an online app oh my gosh
that's so great what was it what was the
app
uh
to be honestly i don't remember
it's been years now
oh your other girlfriend i bet she's so
incredible
she loves this
um
so yeah you met on the internet just
like millions and millions of other
couples have and i we went to
uh i don't know we went somewhere and
then we
had you i think that's where you have
that conversation
as your kid get gets older you can be
more honest but dude i really recommend
answering questions only that your kid
asks there may come a day when your kid
is 18 or 22 or 30 and y'all are out and
you want to have a a conversation
conversation that's cool but that's less
that's more about them getting to know
their origin story and less about dad
trying to make himself feel better
or mom trying to make herself feel
better
probably what's going to happen is she's
going to be in high school and
somebody's going to cheat on her and
she's going to be devastated by it and
she's going to say you don't know what
this is like you don't know me you don't
know what's happening and you're going
to say i got a story for you
and that's when you can connect
empathetically with your dog you say hey
our stories are more similar than you
think but don't ever ever ever lie
okay my friend rachel says share don't
scare right the thing you don't want to
communicate to your kid is yeah this
could happen any time again
any time and by the way we're still
cheating even though even since you've
been born we're still cheating we're
just a couple of cheaters like that's
what's gonna freak your kid out and give
her an uh she's going to not have a
stable foundation to build her her
esteem off of her support networks her
relationships off of if she thinks at
any moment one of these two are going to
go again and create another family
somewhere else that's what you want to
avoid right
okay so have you had that conversation
like how does this go with you and your
wife
uh
i'm i'm not sure what you're asking
when you all discuss like what do we
think we should do what i'm interested
in y'all's answers
um we we've always just said we met we
we met online that's what we would say
when time comes that's a hundred percent
accurate 100 percent fair
okay you don't have to tell them that
mom and dad weren't great people and tim
quit cheating
understood you promised
in front of america
in front of all 17 listeners oh there's
no there's 19 now sucker we picked up
two over the holidays it was awesome
so big weekend
yeah we had a big weekend that's right
um
why is she cheating on you
uh
i
i don't know
i think i was
uh working more
than uh
than she uh liked with having a new baby
at home and maybe it was just another
source of attention
hmm
did you ever go to marriage counseling
uh we haven't okay
so
i want you all to make that a a1
priority because i don't think it is i
think you all are white-knuckling your
way through it right now
and your need for attention or your
inability to give each other care or to
even say here's what i need from you and
i can provide that or i can't provide
you all need to go learn some language
and some tools
okay your daughter's worth that y'all
two are worth that you my brother are
worth that
and
the answer you gave isn't the reason she
would cheat
and
but i
i want you all to get into a room and
say all right we are actually in a good
place right now we're not on life
support we're not trying to deal with
somebody else cheated somebody else did
something things are good
we want to cheat proof this marriage we
want to create an environment where that
never ever ever happens again and let's
start from square one and if y'all do
that you can build something
extraordinary and strong that will last
forever
yes if you don't you're going to be
calling me back in a few months or a few
years and we're going to be having a
whole different conversation and i don't
want that for you and i don't want that
for that sweet little girl
yes is that cool
yeah absolutely awesome commit to that
brother you're worth that your wife's
worth that and up man that beautiful
beautiful little girl's worth that dude
don't cheat and don't lie to your kids
we'll be right back on the dr john de
luna show
hey good folks and friends and listeners
to the dr john dolone's show the world
is bonkers right we all know this and
one of the most common questions i get
is how do i find a counselor in the
chaos i've reached out and there's a six
month waiting list or i can't afford it
or they only take insurance i can't get
off work and time to go see somebody
it's way across town what do i do
because i want help with my anxiety my
depression my relationships are hanging
on by a thread i want to be a better mom
i gotta process this trauma that
happened to me when i was a kid
where do i find a counselor
so i partnered with betterhelp because
betterhelp is customized online therapy
that offers video phone even live chat
sessions so you don't even have to look
at your therapist when you're talking to
them if you don't want to i've taken
away all your excuses and it's more
affordable than in-person therapy and
these are real licensed therapists if
you reach out to them you will be
talking to somebody within 48 hours dr
john daloni show listeners get 10 off
their first month at betterhelp.com
please reach out if you need help that's
betterhelp.com
all right we are back jack let's go to
lisa in milwaukee wisconsin what's up
lisa
hey how are you i'm so good how are you
good
um
i have a little bit of drama to share
with you
[Laughter]
oh sweet hey the last caller
was with somebody and his wife was with
somebody and then they hooked up and had
a kid so you got to beat that go
yeah hopefully it's not as bad but i
don't know
so my boyfriend is 36 years old and he
still lives with a roommate but his
roommate is his ex
and i'm wondering how do i move forward
with him
[Laughter]
you may have just won this is awesome
you may have just you may have just
defeated
the last caller lisa
so you were dating a guy who's 38 how
long you've been together
um so we've only been together for six
months
and
do you love him
i do love him rose okay so you love him
and
there's just one little hang-up is um he
lives with his ex-girlfriend still
yeah
why why does he do that why are you
putting up with that um well okay so
they've been together
like living together for years now like
seven years
and they're friends he says they're just
friends who thinks of her is just one of
the guys
that he can have sex with
but she has a boyfriend okay okay
oh my gosh i want you to listen to the
last call
uh-huh and then you can come back and
just put yourself right back into this
call just now
there's a 100 chance they're hooking up
a hundred
okay a thousand percent chance
and even if they weren't
the toxicity around this is so
disturbing
and what's most disturbing to me is that
you have settled for this how old are
you
i'm 29.
why
why has this been where you think this
is what this is the best i can do i
guess
the problem is i should tell you that i
have borderline personality disorder
okay so and i have ptsd so i just feel
like i can't trust my intuition anymore
i don't know like if they're hooking up
if they're not like i'm constantly
fighting myself on if they're not
um i i'm seeing a therapist a good a
good and she says
that the roommate's just there
you should find a new therapist number
one number two this isn't about what
they're doing
okay i i did that to for some theater
because we're on the radio
what matters here is
you
think that you're defective or broken
borderline personality disorder is hard
right you know that you feel a lot right
you feel deeper than most people most of
the time and those feelings and emotions
are
they are powerful right
yeah tell me about your trauma
um
it's uh
sexual assault so
yeah i'm gonna start to cry
and here's
it's still really close to the surface
for you right
yeah and there's a boyfriend
yeah you did it to me so ugh i'm so so
sorry
so
sorry often when i when i hear the
situation about the drama
you have
you and life circumstances and by the
way that kind of trauma changes your
brain
it changes your shame cycle of shame
changes how you see yourself and your
self-worth and your value
you and i have never met and if you
would hear i wouldn't say anything for
the next five minutes i would ask your
permission if i could just give you a
hug and if you said yes i would hug you
for five minutes without saying a word
because i don't know if you can remember
a time
when somebody was with you
without wanting something from you
without wanting sex without wanting
connection without wanting needing you
to go do a thing for me
that someone was just with you because
of you
do you remember that last time
um
it's probably been a while right it's
been like seven years there you go
and i want you to know that you're worth
just being with
and you that trauma's real close to the
top and my guess is if you were honest
and i talked for a while there's
probably some even more trauma back from
when you were younger
is that fair
yeah okay
i want you to heal from that trauma
before you get into another dating
relationship because you're gonna find
yourself dating some guy that still
lives with his ex-girlfriend and says
nah dude everything's cool and you're
gonna make yourself bananas cause you
know it's not right
not that it's not right in the moral
sense it's not right from a value sense
you're worth more than that
and you know that he doesn't look at you
directly
and he'll say all the right things
because man he's got a great gig going
mm-hmm but it's not about that it's
about you
yeah and if you have a a a therapist
that says no that's cool man
just keep loving him dude i got a real
problem with that because that's about
value
yeah
that's true and when i tried to talk to
him about like i was accusing him of
that's something that we do um with bpd
sometimes like we'll have
we'll be so afraid of being alone and
like we'll start these fights and then
like i accuse him of like sleeping with
her even if it wasn't right and then he
got so mad that he broke his hand
on the bar
well he had a bar in his basement and he
just broke his hand over it and i just
felt like that was kind of an
overreaction
uh
you're correct
anytime somebody punches something
because they're so mad
means they're acting like a child my
kids my child does that
because they're a child adults don't do
that adults have self-control and they
have discipline
and they know when to walk
away they don't punch holes and stuff
they don't break their hands on walls
and so
all of this
stemming from
somebody whose body who's not safe in
their own body and they're looking for
somebody else to help them be safe
in that desperation i don't want to be
alone i don't want to be alone and my
feelings are going going going going
going
you man that chaos borderline is hard
borderline is hard hard hard hard hard
but there is healing from it it does
take a while but there's healing
but you gotta really really put in the
work
right
yeah
are you worth it i'm worth it um i guess
i should just be alone right now and
uh here's the thing i'm not gonna tell
you what to do i'm gonna tell you you're
worth more than dating a guy who
lives with his ex-girlfriend
yeah more than that you're worth dating
a guy that you don't think
is cheating on you all the time even if
he's not dude may be incredible dude
maybe stuck in a lease and
whatever probably not but he may be
incredible
and
it's making you insane because of the
living arrangements
yeah
and if he won't move then he's saying i
like my living arrangements more than
your well-being
and he's allowed to do that
but you need to hear that for what it is
and exit building left
he talked about like maybe we can rent a
house together instead but he still
wants to keep her as a tenant and i just
feel like that's equivalent of him
saying like i still want to keep her i
want to i want to keep her somehow
i mean it doesn't sound right
who do you have in your life besides him
that you can sit down and talk talk
about this
um
i'm talking about this with my mom
not your mom not your mom because
there's going to be some other stuff
there with that and you know that right
yeah yeah
um
basically my best friend
who is that
um she's getting married um soon her
name is adrian
do you feel a sense of loss that she's
getting married
um
a little bit yeah
so in that you're gonna mourn that
because she's gonna be signing up to
have somebody else's heart number one
right and that's good and that's but
that's gonna be hard for you
and that may send off your
bpd alarms
right
continue to lever through that okay
that can be hard hard hard i know it's
gonna be hard
and find a counselor that you can work
with and say here's what i've been told
i have diagnostically
and i want to heal from this
and whether it's dbt there's some
there's some really good stuff out there
um that that you can get involved with
that can help with borderline it does
take a while but you can help more
importantly i want you to heal from your
trauma okay i want you to get with a
good trauma counselor in your area
and say i've got to i want to heal from
the sexual assault not that the sexual
assault's ever going to go away but you
will get to a place in healing where
your body won't respond
to every connection moment as though
we're about to be re-traumatized
it can learn to love again and be still
you can feel safe in your own body
but that's right that would be really
nice that's yeah right wouldn't it you
know what you'll be able to do it's so
great you can just go go home from
wherever you are and just lay down and
just go to sleep can you imagine that
would be really nice and you have no
interest you don't smoke weed to just to
get through a day you don't have to have
18
milligrams of i mean 18 milligrams 180
milligrams of caffeine just to get out
of bed in the morning like you it it's
it's a peaceful
and you he need to hear me say lisa
you're worth that healing this guy might
be it for you it might be
but right now that guy's a major trigger
for you
yeah and i don't i'm not a fan of
anybody
dating anybody seriously who still lives
with his ex-girlfriend
that's a maturity issue that's a
priorities issue
you're worth more than that lisa am i
telling you go break up i'm just telling
you whoa
and therapists who are listening to this
show for god's sake
i know the cool thing is to be like
whatever you feel is best for you stop
at some point follow a teary real set
for some point therapist you got to get
involved and you have to say you're
worth more than that
i think you are devaluing yourself
through this relationship or by putting
up with this type of um gaslighting or
abuse or whatever the thing is have some
courage therapist to say that's not a
good idea
i know that's not the cool thing
and you just got to do your own thing
and find out free at some point you got
to take sides you got to help out
be a therapist who cares enough to say
uh that's not that's not smart that's
not serving you well
every time you come in here you sound
more hurt than the last time you were
here and all the hurt seems to be
directed at this one person
is this wise
please please get involved
all right let's wrap up today's show
let's go to the lyrics for the day i
have not listened to these lyrics i
don't know this song
but again my friend
armando
sent me this song and said this is for
your show so armando here we go my
brother
the song
jesus by moby
you love moby huh james i don't love
moby but this song is is at the end
credits of all the born movies and so
with as much drama as this show has had
it kind of fits it actually does and
dude you're like like a good off the
grid guy like bourne's kind of awesome
board is like the poster child fur
that's so cool
man
all right so the song by moby i like
that what was that one record moby did y
the original play i liked that record
and i know it's not cool to say but i
thought it was a great record i haven't
listened to a single thing since but
maybe i'll give moby a shot i'll go out
to
the used cd store and get a bunch of
movie records all right so it's called
extreme ways off the born soundtrack and
it goes like this
extreme ways are back again extreme
places i don't know i broke everything
new again everything that i'd owned i
threw out threw it out the windows came
along extreme ways i know will part the
colors of my s
see
perfect colored me
extreme ways that help me they help me
out late at night extreme places i'd
gone that never see any light dirty
basements dirty noise dirty places
coming through
extreme worlds alone
if you ever like it then
i have no idea what the song is about
but it sounds
just like this show we'll see you soon
take care